- Ronny, can you hear me?
- Yeah, I can hear you.
- Don't get anyone pregnant!
- No one's getting pregnant.
Yes, I know condoms
are not 100 percent effective.
Yes, I know you're supposed to
roll it all the way down the
shaft.
I gotta go.
No, I was... talking to my mom.
- Morning, everyone.
- I'm Ronny.
- And welcome...
- I'm Ashley.
- ...to your first day of law school.
You go, Ronny Chieng!
- Go make a half-white,
half-Asian baby.
- We're just friends, man.
Well, you are one heartbeat
away from looking at her
differently.
- This is Australian
rules football, huh?
- I guess.
Oh my god, that guy just jumped
on that other guy's face.
Ronny Chieng from international
house?
Uh, just having a fight.
Yo, I will move when I am
goddamn ready to move and not
one second earlier.
Nah, I reckon you'll start
moving right now, Chieng.
Oh yeah?
That character is hilarious.
I'm actually not doing a
character right now, I'm just
talking.
- You feeling pumped?
- I'm moderately pumped.